hello everybody welcome welcome as you
are coming in I would love to know where
you are signing in from so if you could
navigate your way to the chat and type
in where you're calling in from so I can
see who all we have in this chat
okay India is in the building Belgium
Saudi Arabia Illinois hey Lisa I'm from
Illinois originally New Jersey Germany
Argentina all over the world I look I
love this about Udacity people we have
people all over the world joining us in
one central location today I see
California Moscow Bangalore us if you're
just joining navigate your way to the
chat and let us know where you are
signing in from Alabama right next door
to me I'm here in Georgia now North
Carolina awesome we have people from
literally all over the world in one
place right now I think that is the
coolest thing ever
and we're also going to be talking about
LinkedIn which is a very global platform
so it's right on topic
okay we'll give a couple more seconds
for people to join in as I pull up the
presentation
let me see if you're just joining let us
know where you're calling in from New
Orleans Federico he's like a webinar
veteran at this point he is here on
everything I am not having any worries
about him landing a job because he's
getting all the knowledge he needs here
at these webinars and workshops Nigeria
North Carolina awesome great so thank
you all for for sharing that information
so today we are going to be talking
about LinkedIn and specifically today
we're going to be talking about your
profile now there are a lot of resources
out there that talk to you about
creating a good profile but there are
some things that I think a lot of people
aren't aware of or they're not trying
new things and seeing what works for
them so I want to give you all some
strategies and ultimately the goal is to
utilize LinkedIn as a platform for
personal branding so that you're drawing
attention to your profile and people are
reaching out to you with intentions of
hiring you so that's why we're doing a
two-part series so it's the LinkedIn
guide to getting job interviews without
applying in the first part is today is
profile optimization and then our next
session is gonna be on engaging and
content creation and that'll be part two
on August 26th so stay tuned make sure
you attend that after both of those
sessions you're getting a lot of really
good value and you can really start to
put things into place that will start
drawing that traffic over to your
profile so my name is Brett Ellis I'm a
career coach here with Udacity I've been
here since mid-april but I've been
working in the career coaching personal
branding space for most of my career
more so in the higher education space so
I've worked with college students
primarily in helping them find jobs upon
graduation but now I work with really a
multiple of age ranges and people at
different points in their career to
really help them showcase the work that
they're due
through personal and professional
branding as well as career coaching and
job search placement as well I love
doing this as my favorite thing I love
the one-on-one but my favorite is
engaging with groups and teaching a lot
of people at one time because I think
it's a great opportunity to learn but to
also connect with other like-minded
people so today we're going to be
talking about why is it important to use
LinkedIn this is probably the number one
question I get because I talk about
LinkedIn to my friends to my family and
I'm always on LinkedIn if you if you
follow me you see me posting quite
frequently I'm always commenting and
engaging so we'll talk about that then
we're just gonna kind of go through what
I would call like the anatomy of a good
LinkedIn profile so we're gonna go
through each step talk about your
profile picture and banner creating a
keyword optimized headline writing an
effective About section summary which is
a big area that I want to touch on today
emphasizing achievements and media in
your experience section that's a good
point I want to make as well and then
one thing that I see a lot of students
need help with is really actually
highlighting their nanodegree throughout
their personal branding documents
especially their LinkedIn and through
their education section and then lastly
we'll talk about recommendations and
using those to establish credibility in
your industry and then we will finish
off with just some questions and some
closing statements from you all
so what I want you all to do is jump
back in the chat and I want you to tell
me very briefly what you hope to gain
from this session what are you hoping to
learn what is your goal after attending
this maybe you've used LinkedIn before
but don't really know how to use it as
effectively drop it in the comments and
let me know what are your major goals or
what are you hoping to gain from this
session any brave volunteers while I
wait my takeaway is that you all start
getting job interviews without applying
that is that is my takeaway for you all
are there any additional takeaways that
people are hoping to gain from this so
if it's not included I can make sure to
touch on it
optimize the profile to highlight key
capabilities and experiences we're
definitely going to touch on that I'm a
college student so I'm looking for
internships I am glad that you brought
that up because I see college students
do very very well on LinkedIn for the
most part us working professionals it's
kind of expected but people are
oftentimes surprised to see college
students very actively engage and those
people tend to find jobs very quickly
they're highly sought out more
information to refine the profile hoping
to get interviews yep build profile
understand highlighting skills ok
struggling to get full-time jobs this
should be helpful looking for
internships how to get top people in my
field to connect with me that's a good
point
something that I'll probably touch a
little bit more on in the next session
but I'll try to make sure that I give a
brief overview of that as well ok so
thank you all for contributing to that
that helps me to have a little bit
better understanding of what you all are
hoping to gain so let us jump right in
this is why you should really be using
LinkedIn so these are my top reasons
you'll hear different reasons from other
people but I can only speak on my
experience and what's worked really well
for me it number one it's one of the
most effective places to find a good job
and sometimes you don't even have to
apply so if you all have been applying
for jobs for months or know people who
have and you're failing or you you know
people who are not doing really well
it's partially because the online
application system is flawed in a sense
where you can apply for any job at any
time from anywhere with any background
so you can apply for something as you
know as low level as like a receptionist
or a front desk assistant or something
like that or the director of a
department there's really nothing
holding you back from applying to those
things so really these recruiters and
employers are flooded with applications
that they have to review so they have a
lot of different systems in place that
they're filtering people out and so
LinkedIn is really good because it's
it's a way for you to showcase what
do as a way to draw their attention to
you so you don't have to do the applying
so that's why I like it
number two it makes it easy to connect
and learn from other like-minded
professionals from around the world so
very similar to Udacity actually they're
there you know there are people from
around the world that you get to connect
with in one place this is not possible
through a resume it's not possible
through a cover letter it's not possible
through your CV to connect with this
many people so it's a great opportunity
not only to build relationships but to
learn as well I tell people all the time
every time I log into LinkedIn it's like
going to a conference it's like going to
a workshop or a networking event you're
connecting with people you're learning
different things number three it's a
great tool for personal branding and
becoming a subject matter expert so for
those of you who are really interested
in taking your career to a high level
you want to be known as somebody who is
an expert in data analytics you want to
be an expert in machine learning you
want to be an expert in AI Lincoln is a
great place for you to establish that
credibility and to start branding
yourself as an expert through that and
we'll talk a lot more about that in the
second session where we're talking about
creating content like posts and articles
and then number four it can help you
create multiple streams of income I
don't know too many people who don't
want multiple streams of income so that
can be really helpful for me it was a
way to really showcase my brand for jobs
but it also helps draw people over to my
profile for me to gain career coaching
clients outside of Udacity as well so
you can kind of kill two birds with one
stone there and build your brand as well
as attract job seekers but also attract
clients with the work that you're doing
so a lot of these things that I'm gonna
share are relevant for both job seekers
and freelancers or entrepreneurs so if
you're in that mindset or that's your
goal a lot of this is gonna be relevant
and transferable alright so moving right
along so I mentioned we were going to
talk specifically about the profile
picture and your banner and so that's
kind of the first thing that you see
when you go to a profile so if you take
a look at my profile
picture it's a high-quality picture it
looks better when it's not a screenshot
I promise but it is a quality picture
I'm dressed appropriately have a nice
you know clean haircut it's it's very
visible to see my face but I think one
of the things that really helps with my
picture is that it showcases me in
action so for me I'm working on building
my brand as a speaker and as a workshop
facilitator so if you see my profile
picture of me actually doing that that
adds another layer to my branding
another thing that you can do is just
you know a simple straight on
professional headshot that works as well
does not need to be you going to a
studio with all of the lighting it could
simply be you know a good phone camera
straight on with good lighting you don't
want to take a selfie you don't want to
have it really dark you don't want to
have weird angles take some time to get
a good picture it makes a big difference
and then you're definitely more likely
to receive page views I think the
statistic is 14 times more likely that
somebody will visit your profile if you
have a picture versus if you don't so
that's something really important for
you to know so that's that's pretty much
it with the profile picture it's not too
much there's not a whole lot you can do
to make that better just make sure that
it has all of those things that we
talked about your banner this is kind of
like this should be towards the bottom
of your priorities list as it relates to
your LinkedIn profile unless maybe
you're a business owner or a freelancer
I mean it's a great way for you to
showcase which you want people to see as
soon as they come to your profile so
it's almost kind of like a storefront if
you think about it so for me I want
people to know exactly what I do as soon
as they get to my page they don't even
have to scroll all the way through and
do those things so it also represents
your represents your brand so you want
to make sure that you have similar
colors for me I use a lot of blue white
grey and black and so that all ties in
from my banner to what I'm wearing in
the picture to some other things there
as well
and if you're looking for an easy way to
create one of these go to canva.com and
then search in LinkedIn banner and it'll
give you the exact dimensions and
some pre-made templates where you can
just go in and change out the
information to replace it with your own
that's a very easy kind of hack to do
that if you're not skilled in graphic
design or creating that banner for
yourself
okay so moving on to the headline this
is extremely important and I don't think
that people realize how much weight this
has so it's really important for keyword
searches specifically but also for
enticing people over to your profile so
I'll talk about the keyword searches
first so if you are on LinkedIn and you
look at the search feature if an
employer was trying to find somebody who
was a data analyst they may type in a
data analyst in that search bar if you
don't have data analyst in your headline
somewhere your chances of going towards
the top of those search results drops
very dramatically so if you are in a
nano degree program focused on data
analytics you want to get a job as a
data analyst you need to have that
somewhere in your headline so that it
contributes to your keyword searches so
if people are looking for somebody who
has that skill set they're finding you
there so your first step needs to be to
think about what recruiters are actually
searching for what are the skill sets
that they're looking for what are the
things that they want to find people for
because this is what they're doing
instead of sometimes reviewing
applications they're skipping that whole
process and they're doing the work of
going out and finding somebody so you
want to showcase that based on what
keywords recruiters are searching for
but you also want to showcase things
that you're actually good at so if you
don't have any experience as a data
analyst and you didn't even do a nano
degree you're not gonna put that there
because you're not you don't have that
skill set you don't have that to offer
so you want to keep those two things in
mind and make sure that both of those
are aligned
what recruiters are searching for and
then what you're good at and what you
want to be known for so here's something
that most people do because LinkedIn
defaults to your current position at
your current company that's just the
default setting that LinkedIn has it's
on you to go and change that the reason
why you don't necessarily want to do
that is because the role of LinkedIn is
not for you to showcase your employers
it's for you to showcase yourself as a
professional in your own personal brand
plus they can go
one step below are two steps below in
your education or in your experience
section and see where you work and what
you do so it's kind of a wasted
opportunity there unless maybe it's part
of your your job duties maybe you work
in sales as Lynn LinkedIn is one of the
tools that you use you may be asked to
kind of make sure that that's present
there but if not you want to be really
focused on your own brand so here's
another example so for those of you who
may be in digital marketing packed full
of keywords and skill sets so digital
marketers specializing in social media
management paid advertising and branch
strategy very simple if those are things
that you're good at and you're going in
digital marketing feel free to steal it
I don't care I'm not holding that one
back but you see for mine
I have things like personal branding
career development speaker college
career again career again so if people
are searching for career I'm gonna go
towards the top and then also LinkedIn
for entrepreneurs and the funny thing
about this is I actually changed this
since then I change mine all the time I
try new things I see what works see what
what doesn't work I get feedback from
people and then I make adjustments based
on that another cool thing about this
section is let's just say for example I
woke up tomorrow morning and I decided I
wanted to give up all of this career
coaching all of this speaking and I
wanted to be a graphic designer
because I can do some graphic design
I could literally shift my entire
branding make my banner focused on
graphic design maybe take another
picture of me at my laptop change my
headline to graphic designer and then I
would start to be found for that so you
really want to make sure that you're
focused on what you want to be found for
and not just a comprehensive list of all
the things that you do and that goes for
your Linkedin your resume everything
everything should be targeted on your
next step and not necessarily a
comprehensive list of everything you've
ever done okay so now I want you to take
some time to think and I would love for
a couple of you to share again just drop
in the comments let me know what are
some important key words for you to
consider and what are some key words
that recruiters might search to find you
and the types of roles that you're
looking for what are those employers
looking for so if you're in digital
marketing what are they looking for if
you're in data analytics what are they
looking for if you're going for
artificial intelligence what are they
looking for okay copywriter good machine
learning engineer software engineer
software developer data scientist great
front-end web developer these are all
good brand manager machine learning deep
learning so I like that you put
enthusiast though I want to talk about
that piece specifically because I see a
lot of people put enthusiasts or
aspiring both of those can sometimes
have a negative connotation because I
could personally be a machine learning
enthusiast I have no idea what goes into
machine learning I have no nano degree
background I have no education have no
work experience so sometimes you want to
be careful with that language and
calling yourself like an enthusiast cuz
that just may mean that you're
passionate about something it doesn't
necessarily reflect on your skill set to
do that
ok business analyst data analyst okay
great
these are all really good but you can
build on them a little bit more kind of
going back to that example so let's say
you do go the business analyst and you
want that to be kind of your focus you
could say something like business
analyst specializing in and then include
two or three more keywords or you could
do like business analysts predictive
analytics expert or something like that
just play around with different things
and see what works but really utilize
that whole space I recommend utilizing
that entire space because it really
contributes to your keyword searches
awesome ok moving right along so the
next section I want to talk about is
your About section or your summary so
they're they kind of interchange the
titles with that this is a strategy that
I came up with to help you kind of
remember and I call it the skip strategy
I called it that because if you don't do
this they might skip over your profile
but so let's go through it a little bit
so most people I see theirs will say
something like dynamic
with ten years of experience it's very
movie trailer X but you want to make it
to where it's a little bit more
personable because this section is
really the only area throughout your
entire profile that you get to showcase
some personality everything else is kind
of a bunch of different moving puzzle
pieces this is an area for you to
showcase some personality and really
bring everything together so the S
stands for story so you want to share
your career story you want to talk
briefly about your background you want
to talk some about what you're currently
doing because those are things that are
gonna provide people with the context
that's going to be helpful for you in
understanding how they can help you if
they've come to visit your profile so
make sure that you tell that very
briefly Rachel if you could drop the
link to the webinar that Angela did on
your perfect pitch that can be a really
great resource for you in terms of
building out that story a little bit and
this is also something that you can
utilize when you're in an interview and
they ask you to tell me about yourself
that's a great webinars or good resource
for you in building your Linkedin
summary as well as answering that kind
of question or if you're just out at a
networking event and people ask you what
you do does all that webinars great for
all of those things the next thing is
keywords again so keywords are going to
be pulled very strongly from your
headline as well as your summary so you
can find ways to infuse those keywords
so if machine learning is important
maybe include that somewhere in your
narrative or you can tell your story and
then at the bottom put like top
strengths or unique skill sets and then
include those kind of keywords just back
to back and more of a list format but
make sure you have keywords there as
well because that contributes to your
search ability as well your interests so
this is really important because like I
mentioned somebody may not know how they
can help you when they go to your
profile if you don't state that upfront
to them so if you're looking for a role
you don't have to be up front and say
I'm looking for a job or say I'm
unemployed and I need to find work you
can say something like I'm looking for
I'm always open to opportunities to
further my
career in artificial intelligence or
something like that so that people know
if they have opportunities how they can
help you because even if recruiters are
not finding your profile maybe somebody
else is and they're gonna connect you to
somebody else that's what a lot of
people do on LinkedIn it's very helpful
in it just in the spirit of like helping
each other move up in life so make sure
you do that and then also try to include
some personal interests there as well
don't spend too much time on this
because it's still a professional
network at the end of the day but you
still want to showcase things because
that gives people things to talk about
if they are to reach out to you and they
may have something from there that they
can use as an icebreaker so I think mine
says something like I have been called a
certification addict which means I just
really like to learn and I like to
pursue certifications and then I put
something like someday I'd love to be
known as a public speaker a concert
venue owner and a little league baseball
coach so just a very brief kind of hint
at some things that I love so that
people may be able to connect with me on
that passion as well which leads us into
a good last point which is passion this
is very missed in the tech space I know
how a lot of people in tech think but as
it relates to personal branding you want
people to be energized around you you
want people to know that you love what
you do you want people to be able to see
that throughout all of the work that you
do and this is a great area for you to
really show enthusiasm towards what
you're working for so maybe you're
including something about pursuing a
nano degree because you found a passion
maybe you are changing careers and
you're going from something completely
different to something in the tech space
state that in this area this is a great
opportunity for you to address potential
red flags this is a great opportunity
for you to avoid any confusion and state
things up front so you can be
transparent about that but you want
people to have an understanding that you
love the work that you do and then you
can clear up any potential confusion
there as well
let me take a look at this question is
there any way to convey the reason for a
change in career focus so yes how can
you make it appealing great so yeah um
that is a great opportunity for you to
do that that's why you want to tell your
story so let's say for example you were
a teacher you're a math teacher you can
share that in your summary and say
something like I spent the first five
years of my career teaching math and I
loved being able to help students learn
whatever as my career interests have
changed I found a passion for data
analytics and that led me to
intentionally take upon myself to enroll
in a nano degree program through Udacity
where I've learned keyword keyword
keyword keyword and now I'm hoping to
transition my career to that whatever
something like that if you don't provide
that context people are going to go
through your profile and see well he is
the teacher here a teacher here and a
teacher here why is he trying to be a
data analyst when he you know they're
gonna have questions they should never
have questions out of confusion from
your profile their only question should
be wanting to learn more and honestly
like how much do they have to pay you
that's my strategy that's my goal is
that you should always have everything
up front because it eliminates any type
of confusion that people have when they
go to your profile so if you are
changing careers which many Udacity
students are this is a great place to
tell that story and to provide that
context okay so jumping down to the
experience section this area is one of
the most important because it's the most
important in general I think this is
probably the most common question that I
get from Udacity students in general
about like gaining experience so think
about what that means to employers this
is oftentimes the first quarter the
first section that they're looking at if
they're in a hurry and they really want
to find somebody they may skip through
your entire summary and go straight to
your experience and see what you've done
so what you want to really make sure
you're doing here is focusing on your
achievements which really means
highlighting your impact you don't want
to provide a big blocky pair
of text describing your company they can
do their own research to find that out
you don't want to provide a big blocky
paragraph about your roles and
responsibilities that often times can
either be assumed or it's not as
important as the impact that you're
providing so if you think about any job
opening or any client need is a
opportunity it's a problem that needs to
be solved or it's a goal that they want
to accomplish so if you don't showcase
your ability to solve problems or your
ability to achieve goals you're missing
a huge opportunity and so as you're
thinking about some of your past
positions you really want to focus on
what are the results that you have
contributed to the organization or the
company or whatever it is if all you do
is say I do this I do this I run this I
manage this you don't do anything to
showcase whether or not you were
actually good at your job or that you
actually made a meaningful impact on the
organization so you really want to
showcase that Rachel if you could
there's a there's another webinar that I
did previously on writing achievement
statements and that can be really
helpful for you in terms of creating
that experience section and showcasing
what you've done in the past in a more
impactful way so we have a another
previous webinar that we can include the
link to that video for you to kind of go
back on your own time so as I said
highlight your impact showcase
problem-solving write it out using the
strategy that you'll learn in that other
webinar and that can be really helpful
for you in terms of showcasing your
impact so there are some people who
don't even do that but if you compare
those two think about it like this one
profile says runs departmental Instagram
page versus this person who says that
they increase social media and
engagement by a hundred and fifty
percent as a result of hosting live
events creating engaging content and
putting out articles and resource guides
which one of those is more appealing
obviously the one that showcases the
impact and this person kind of falls to
the wayside now if you want to take that
to the next level which all of you
should want to is uploading media
showcasing the work that
done through work samples so you're
changing your mindset about what a
LinkedIn profile is supposed to do I
like to think of a LinkedIn profile as a
living breathing portfolio so this is an
opportunity for you to showcase your
best work for you to showcase the most
relevant work to what you're looking for
based on what you've done in previous
positions so as you're thinking about
some of your past positions one you want
to make sure that you're showcasing
transferable things so if you're going
from one job that's a little bit
unrelated from what you're trying to do
showcase the things that are related
don't give a list of ten achievements
and only two of them are actually
closely related to that new role make it
as transferable as you possibly can and
the same goes for media where we use a
very consistent strategy here in the
careers team Udacity is the Show and
Tell method so it's very easy to say
that you've done something it's another
thing to be able to prove it with data
or with samples so a couple of ideas to
get you thinking our pictures videos
graphics so especially if you're in kind
of like the digital marketing space
you're should be flooded with different
visual graphics now for those of you who
may be on kind of like the the data side
or the coding side that's a little bit
more challenging because one those
things are not aesthetically pleasing on
the backend and two a lot of times those
things are confidential and so you have
to think a little bit more outside the
box in terms of what media you might
upload and I just wanted to kind of you
know mention that this is by no means
like required if you don't do this it's
not like you will never get a job it's
just one way to take it to the next
level so it's helpful to be able to
showcase some of your previous projects
and so a couple of things that you can
think of if those aren't relevant for
you is maybe including links to websites
if you've helped develop those reports
if you do any type of work with data
maybe focus more specifically on the
output the data visualizations the
charts the the presentations that you
may have given you can go back in and
redact copy
information or replace it people just
kind of want to get an understanding of
how you do the work that you do and
another thing is even if none of those
things work you can potentially upload
recommendation letters or client
testimonials for me
personally if you look at my profile I
have a combination of just about
everything I have videos I have pictures
I have powerpoints I have newsletters I
have Flyers
I have how-to guides in PDF format I
like to showcase a wide range of things
but another thing to think about is if
you don't have any media if you can't
think of any media from your previous
positions keep this in the back of your
mind as you progress throughout your
career whenever you take on a major
project one of the things that pops into
your head should be how can I showcase
this once I'm done how can I visualize
this to where it's aesthetically
pleasing or simplified enough to where
people would understand what I'm talking
about
and this is something that I really
pride myself on is being very
intentional about the work that I'm
doing and doing things that are gonna
benefit my employer and benefit me at
the same time so keep that in mind as
you go throughout your career as you
think about maybe the current position
that you're in or your future position
how can you document your experience and
document your impact at that place so
that future employers can see that one
way to take it like even even further is
to connect those achievements to your
media so a couple of things that I've
done is talk about being contracted to
do workshop series and then I have media
that they can go look at that showcases
pictures as well as survey data from
that specific achievement so that's just
one way to really take it up a notch and
my goal with that is if I'm doing the
right things with my keyword searches if
I'm putting out content people are drawn
to my profile then they see my work then
they see that I've done good work then
they can actually go and see samples of
my work compare that to the person who's
doing the bare minimum and this person
is much more likely to get hired and so
I would even share like my experience
here with Udacity and the position I had
before this both of those experiences
came through LinkedIn without me ever
having to apply and I would
that a lot to my ability to showcase my
impact as well as show relevant work
samples so keep those things in mind a
lot of people get discouraged here
because they don't have things that they
can showcase but think about if that's
an issue how can you address that in the
future so I see we have a couple of
questions here can the showcase examples
be links to projects yes I think that's
a great idea
I think that you can also do that in
your education section as well you can
include links and media there which a
lot of people don't know you can do it
in your experience section as well as
your education so if you're I think
we'll talk about that in a minute
a good question what about fresh
graduates what to write in this
important section you may not have a lot
to talk about but you can utilize your
education section to showcase some
projects that you've done through your
nano degree program through your college
degree program through a certification
program anything like that is great for
you to upload but if you don't have any
work experience we can't create that for
you so just keep that in your mind as
you go through your career and think
about how you may document that okay I'm
considering entering the workforce on
the same field designing a building
software I've learned show they get
unemployment and be prepared to explain
why any other so that's a great question
if there's any reason why you have a gap
so maybe you're returning back to the
workforce maybe you did an
entrepreneurial venture for a while
maybe you had to take time to take care
of your family whether you had a baby or
had to take care of an elderly family
member or something like that I think
it's always helpful for you to fill in
that gap with something don't make
things up don't put any fluff there but
tell people what happened in that time
frame as long as you feel comfortable
with that if you don't feel comfortable
sharing that you were taking care of a
family member then you may just have to
be confident with that gap and be
prepared to have that conversation when
employers ask I will say in my
experience employers are a lot more
worried when the gap is current then
when it's in the past so if you're
working somewhere now but you had a ten
year gap before that I don't think that
employers are stressing that too much
where sometimes can become a
Flagg is if you have experience
experience experience and like a 2/3 or
gap with no explanation that at that
point they're gonna wonder what have you
been doing for the last few years so you
always want to try to find a way to
showcase that even if all you're doing
is nano degree programs and building
your experience just create a position
that says something like a student and
then include the things there so they
can see what you've been doing in there
at that time some recruiters will
actually go throughout your profile and
see ok they were working on a master's
degree at that time it makes sense but
you never want to allow them the
opportunity to make negative assumptions
you really want to tell your story the
way you want them to hear it
let me see
let me let me take these questions
towards the end I just want to make sure
we get through the presentation if I
didn't answer your question feel free to
copy and paste it later but I want to
make sure that we get through the rest
of the presentation and if you have any
further questions you can reach out to
me via slack or student hub privately ok
so here's an example of my current
position here with Udacity so I provide
a very brief description of what I do
here because for the most part people
can have a good understanding of what a
career coach does so I don't spend too
much time on that and I focused more
specifically on achievements I've only
been here since mid-april so I don't
have a ton of things to talk about but
so one thing that I did is the previous
webinar that I mentioned was
facilitating this how to write
achievement statements and I showcase my
impact by showing how many views that it
received so 1.4 thousand views on
YouTube it's pretty impressive for the
right employer they may go to my profile
and see oh we're looking for somebody
who can facilitate webinars oh we're
working with somebody who can deliver
workshops online or we're looking for
somebody with the experience using zoom
I've listed all of that in one very
brief impactful section so think about
that as you're working on highlighting
your skills and then I took it a step
further and uploaded a link to that from
the YouTube video that I mentioned
earlier so they can go in and they could
actually watch that if they wanted to
but it's a good way to showcase the
impact as well as provide a relevant
work sample and I've only been here
since April so it kind of goes to show
you like this is a mindset for me I
haven't been here for years on end so if
you've been out of coming for a very
long time and you have nothing to show
for it I would challenge you to think a
little bit more outside the box and how
you can showcase the work that you're
doing because it's not as hard as a lot
of people make it out to be you just
have to be in that mindset going into it
as well as think outside the box in ways
that you can showcase your impact let's
see ok ok so I want you to jump back in
the chat again let me know what are some
things that might work for you in terms
of uploading media
on your experience section so in your
past jobs maybe right now you're working
as a freelancer maybe you're doing some
volunteer work what are some specific
things that you could potentially upload
as media in your experience section
article links github links great yep
what else videos videos are awesome
especially on social media what else
built websites awesome great example
blog links showcase volunteer work
that's a good question i if you have
intensive volunteer work and you don't
have a lot of work experience i would
say put that in your experience section
because it's still experience a lot of
people downplay their volunteer
experience because there's a section for
that but I would recommend you putting
it there especially if you have a gap
volunteering is a great way to fill that
gap but it's also a great way to
showcase education because just because
you're not getting paid for something
does not mean it's not a job so doing
the same treating that the same exact
way you would do a real job showcase
your impact showcase media link to
customer testimonials that's awesome
another thing that you can do is look
into recommendations but we'll talk
about a little bit later mailing
campaign templates yes I also have do my
own email marketing for my business so
another thing that you could showcase is
your open rates as well as like your
click rates and different things like
that so that's a really good one as well
as just the templates are great too okay
so let's keep it moving some of you have
asked questions that we'll talk about a
little bit later so I'll answer those as
we go does being a mentor at Udacity
come under volunteering I think you
could put that under experience I think
you could definitely do that there okay
moving right along recommendations so
this is an area that I find very
important that I see as a huge missed
opportunity for a lot of people if you
think about it they're a lot like Amazon
reviews so if you ever go to buy
something on Amazon or maybe you go to
check out a new restaurant on Yelp or
something like that maybe there are
different platforms where you're located
but the first thing that we normally do
is jump straight to those reviews or
jump straight to that rating some people
do this with LinkedIn as well if they're
deciding that they want to hire you or
they want to work with you a lot of them
will jump directly down to your actual
recommendations and see if people vouch
for your work because one it adds
credibility but it also contributes to
this thing called social proof which for
any of you in digital marketing you have
an understanding that social proof is a
great tool that we use to help sell
things so if ten people have said that
this is a great person to work with
chances are I'm more likely to believe
them than I am to just believe that one
person who's saying that they're great
so it can be really helpful for you to
put recommendations on your profile and
just get in the habit of asking for them
ask previous supervisors ask colleagues
that you currently work with if you are
doing freelancing or entrepreneur ask
your clients to leave you
recommendations it's been really really
helpful for me in terms of gaining new
clients I've had people actually
approach me and say I saw one of my
friends left you a recommendation I
didn't even know that they worked with
you and so that's why I decided to be a
client of yours so a couple of easy way
to get them x' is to give them first so
if you want your colleague or your
coworker to give you one just go and
write them one for something that
they're trying to be known for so you
want to make sure that it's targeted and
you want to make it easy so give one to
them first
and then request one if you go through
actual linked and I'll show you how to
request one but in it you can make it
very easy for somebody and just say hey
I'd love for you to leave me a
recommendation based on your experience
working with me at this company and
doing this type of work that you know
insert work that you want to be known
for so if go to your profile they can
see this person is vouching for their
ability to work with machine learning or
do something with web development or
whatever you make that easy for them and
tell them exactly what you want to talk
about and once again this this section
is important for job seekers as well as
entrepreneurs because for the most part
that social proof is very helpful for
you in terms of establishing credibility
my customers my colleagues are not on
LinkedIn I get that I get that
definitely understand that I understand
that a lot of people are not on LinkedIn
and they're not becoming active on
Linkedin it
one of the reasons why I wanted to do
this session because I see LinkedIn
growing very rapidly right now and I
think it'll only continue to grow so as
early as you can start to implement
these things as possible the better
because once everybody decides to join
LinkedIn at that point you'll be like
I've been I've been waiting for this to
happen so once again these are just best
practices these are my suggestions these
are not things that are required from
employers these are just things to take
your your your your profile to the next
level so if you don't have anything here
just keep this in mind as you continue
to go through if your colleagues are on
LinkedIn later
you know then ask them but once again
like I said most people don't have a lot
of recommendations if any so you're not
behind it's just another way to stand
out amongst other people for college
students who could we give or get them
from you could honestly get together
with a couple of people in your class
and do that if you're doing a group
project just tell everybody hey we're
each gonna spend some time after this
project and write a recommendation for
each person then you already potentially
have like three four five
recommendations on your profile already
just from one simple project so
sometimes it's about encouraging other
people to get on LinkedIn and utilize it
as a way to help build their own
personal brand but also if you if you
work at the college obviously a
supervisor there could help professors
if you're close to them don't just ask a
random teacher to give you a
recommendation you want to actually have
a relationship I am unemployed for the
past eight months can I enter the title
of self learning in my experience
section I think you definitely can I
think that's a great way to explain what
you've been doing and then you can
showcase the different things that
you've been working on there I think
that that's that's an extremely good
idea for you to put that as your actual
job title you could do that yep okay I
think we're almost done yeah okay so I
would love to get some brief questions
before I go through some things on
LinkedIn so if there were questions that
I didn't answer before please put them
in the chat now and I'm gonna try to get
through as many as I can and still get
to the platform
so would you keep track of all your past
duties that were not necessarily
achievements I am a big advocate for
keeping everything I am a hoarder as it
relates to work and so I keep files I
keep presentations I keep old resumes I
do that I have a master document that I
use and I think that's important because
like you said sometimes you forget let's
say for example we'll go back to the
teacher example let's say you were a
math teacher and want to transition to a
data analyst and you get rid of all your
stuff about creating lesson plans and
classroom management and all that stuff
and then you become a data analyst and
then you want to go back to maybe
teaching but you want to be a lead
teacher or a principal or something like
that then you have all of those old ones
that you can pull back on as well but if
you kind of delete that and start new
you kind of miss that opportunity so I'm
a big fan of keeping track of everything
I do I have different media and
achievements as far back as my as my
last year in college and so I'm always
keeping track of the work that I'm doing
because you never know when it can be
helpful to utilize again okay how and
where can I show that I am looking for a
job abroad that's a great question
that's a very difficult question I don't
have a great answer for that I don't
think that there is a good way to
showcase that you're looking abroad
unless you include that in your summary
which is really the only place that that
makes sense to do that for you you're
not going to and this goes for everybody
if you're looking for jobs abroad you're
probably not going to get a lot of
attention from employers so if you're
trying to transition from one country to
another people are not going out of
their way to try to hire internationally
not in my experience a lot of employers
are open to hiring internationally but
they're not going out of their way to
find talent in different countries it's
just it's already hard enough to find
talent locally recruiters and employers
just don't have time to do that and so
as they're searching for employees to
hire a lot of them are looking locally
first
that's just how those keyword searches
are populating because another thing
that contributes to that search result
is sometimes location and also the
amount of connections that you have in
common so you know naturally you're more
likely to have more locate more
connections where you're located and so
it's much easier for you to be found in
the actual place that you're looking so
that's good to know I'm glad you asked
that question but it can be very hard so
I would say include that in your summary
as well as you're going to have to be
much more aggressive with your outreach
in terms of connecting with employers
and reaching out to people through
LinkedIn as a way to try to connect ask
questions schedule phone calls video
chats whatever you can to get your you
know name known for whatever work you
want to be doing good question though do
we add scholarship programs I think it
depends I think if all it was is you
know paying for your ability to attend a
course I don't know that that is
relevant in any of those sections
there's definitely some sections where
you can include like awards
accomplishments achievements I don't see
people going down and looking at that
section too frequently it is an area
that you can include but if all it is is
that you got funding for a program
that's not going to be as appealing as
you sharing experience or anything like
that so it's definitely something you
can include I didn't go through every
single section of LinkedIn I went
through the things that I in my
experience are the most important and
the things that recruiters look for the
most so there are definitely some pieces
that I didn't cover so take some
independent research to look at some of
those other sections but those that I
went over are kind of the most important
as it relates to your profile can I add
nanodegrees in the experience section as
well
apart from education you can there's
nothing stopping you from doing that I
think it's better if you go the route of
saying something like the person
mentioned earlier with like self
learning and showcase all of the
different things that you've been
working on that in that gap but you
still do want to have Udacity in your
education section and I think that
that's important to mention as well
something I forgot to talk about but
include your Nana
degree in your education section even if
you're not finished with it some people
will wait until they're done put
something like let's say you're doing
the algorithms and data structures let's
say like you just put that as the title
and then just put in progress next to it
and then you can add Udacity under it
and then you can also upload media where
you're uploading some of the projects
that you're completing or links to
github but definitely put that there
even if you're not done just say that
it's in progress how can you approach
looking for work as a graphic designer
web developer or should the goal be to
just focus on one thing at a time that's
a great question
these are all great questions um I would
say you can definitely you can
definitely try both I think it's always
easier as it relates to anything
personal branding or branding in general
for you to have a very targeted focus
I've struggled in my own experience kind
of going between like the career coach
and the speaker people are like well
which one do you do and I'm like I do
both so for me it's important to push
both but I know for a fact that if I was
to focus on one or the other I would
probably be more successful in one or
the other but I personally enjoy doing
both and so I like pushing both so
that's up to you as a personal decision
is too many media or visuals it too is
that bad I don't think so
I don't think you can have too many
because even if you upload multiple
it'll cut off some so you have to click
like more to see what else they have
career change what should be added in
the headline the current role or the
future role so always always always
thinking futuristically your whatever
you're currently doing is not gonna help
you if you're looking for something
completely different because it's not
going to contribute to your keyword
searches and if your headline says
something that you're currently doing
that's not related people are not gonna
go click on your profile because that's
not what they're looking for so you
always want to think futuristically when
it comes to your headline and your your
brand in general if you've been laid off
how do you address this I would put
something in that description where you
have your position you could even put
like laid off it's not the most
attractive title but you could put
something in the description that says
like laid off due to a reduction in
workforce or a 40% reduction in work
work for something like that to address
that this is my personal opinion I'm a
big fan of addressing every single thing
up front because I it the worst thing
you can do in me to me as a person is
waste my time and so I don't like to
waste my own time I don't like to waste
other people's time if they have an
issue with the information that I'm
presenting they can know that in the
beginning versus we have to go through
two three interviews and then you decide
you don't want me because of those
issues so I I'm a big fan of putting
everything upfront that's a personal
decision though if I was an intern and a
creative agency do I write my position
as an intern or creative copywriter you
don't want to lie about your position
but I think if that's if you were doing
creative copywriting I think you can
definitely include that as your as your
title or you could do something like
creative copywriter parenthesis intern
so they have an understanding if you
were only there for maybe like two
months they understand that like you
didn't get fired you didn't get laid off
it was just a short term so I'm a big
fan of doing things like laid off
reduction and work force temporary
intern contract let them know up front
so there aren't questions you keep
hearing me say I don't want anybody to
have any questions except will you fit
in how much do you charge
that that's my personal mentality okay
let's see how to indicate that you're
looking for remote work I think the only
way you can do that is in your summary
okay it's okay to put student it is okay
to put student in your current role you
can you can do anything you want with
your profile there's there's not really
things that are that are frowned upon if
you're trying to provide context if
you're trying to explain a situation
where an employer might ask a question I
think that that's that's always gonna be
helpful if you're establishing things
upfront so that they know why you have a
gap or they know why you're not
currently working you're stating that
upfront and then you have your education
below it to back it up
okay and I want to be considered as
Canada brand director how should I work
in a headline in summary okay so that's
a good question so what I would love for
all of you to do if you're interested if
you'd like some feedback I have some
homework for everybody I would love for
you all to take some time maybe today
maybe tomorrow I'm gonna give you a
deadline let's see today is Tuesday by
the end of the day tomorrow I'm gonna
make it quick because this is it
shouldn't take you too long put your new
LinkedIn headline in the careers section
of student hub and tag me and I will go
through those and look at those on like
Thursday or Friday and see if I can
provide some feedback but I want to make
that sense of urgency because I want you
all to go through and actually do it
sooner rather than later so I do want to
show you one last thing
I know we had a lot more questions we do
have some upcoming webinars so stay
tuned for those I also mention that
there's that one that we're having at
the end of the month that will be
focused specifically on engaging on the
platform as well as creating content so
I want to make sure that I'm sharing the
right screen okay so one of the things
that I wanted to show you all is if you
go to your actual profile there are some
things that I didn't include in the
presentation that I've found kind of
since then and if you scroll down
you can see it mine is a ton of media a
lot of videos articles presentations
different things like that
if you look at this area let me see the
skills and endorsements area there's a
new feature where you can actually take
a skill quiz and none of these are
really relevant for me but I think some
of them might actually be really helpful
for you all because a lot of them are
tech based and I am NOT a tech expert so
this is a great opportunity for some of
you who might be a little bit more
familiar with some of these languages
software platforms and different
programs those can be really helpful
that will give you kind of like a stamp
of approval in that area and that can be
really helpful for you in terms of
establishing credibility once again so
another thing that I wanted to mention
is in this section you can take that
skills quiz but you really want these
top three skills to be the top three
skills that you want to be known for so
if what you're doing is is not related
to what is currently listed in your
skills that's something that you might
want to change I personally have done
enough social media to where I might
personally change this after putting a
little bit more thought into it I'm not
gonna jump and change it now but I may
change that because these two are really
the top things that I'm looking for and
I may bump career coaching back up which
was previously there but your top three
skills you want to be listed there the
things that you really want to be known
for
but yeah the other only other thing that
I wanted to show to you all is the
student hub a lot of people aren't
familiar with the student hub or where
it's located
but it's located within the classroom
where you kind of complete to work on
your nano degree program but here here's
your career portal where you go to sign
up for career coaching sessions as well
as look at those career projects that we
have but here's the student hub this
purple message looking icon and it will
take you to the page I was actually just
at but then if you go to the careers
page we have a chat here this is very
similar to the careers channel within
slack but we're trying to shift a lot of
our content over to this location versus
slack so you'll start to see us post a
lot more here this is where I'd love for
you all to type in your headline and tag
me in it so I can look at it and provide
some feedback but other than that we
have a couple more minutes is there any
any last questions or overarching
questions if it's too specific I want to
make sure this is gonna be helpful for
everybody but if there are any questions
that you have specifically regarding
like your LinkedIn profile let me know
now
but if this was helpful if you feel like
this was interesting make sure that you
check out our upcoming events on our
events calendar book market if you don't
have it on there already check in
periodically to see some of the events
that we're hosting but the one that
we're having on the 26th is gonna be
focused specifically on LinkedIn again
and it is going to be highlighting
engagement on the platform as well as
starting to create content that's where
you can really start to establish
yourself as a subject matter expert and
draw a lot more traffic over to your
profile
I'm not check the link that Rachel put
in there to get access to that if you
don't have access to student hub feel
free to email support at Udacity comm
and let them know that you're having
issues accessing the the student hub if
you don't have access to that submit
that email ticket so that they can
provide that opportunity for you let's
take this one last question then we're
going to sign off if the job opportunity
is posted in another foreign language
can I submit my resume in English is
this fine that's a tough question I
think this is my personal opinion if
it's posted in a different language I
would more than likely think that
they're looking for somebody to submit
the application in that languages as
well but if you have questions always
feel free to create an additional
like profile if you want to because you
can oh yeah yep just like Nikolas says
you can have profiles in different
languages that's more so focused on kind
of LinkedIn but if it's like resume you
might have to you might have to kind of
follow what they're looking for or reach
out and find somebody at that company
and ask them that question but thank you
all if you are interested in connecting
with me I can drop my I'll drop my
LinkedIn here it's very simple if you
want to use mine as kind of an example
I've had some people who have requested
that but feel free to connect with me
I'm always always always posting content
giving job search advice helping people
with their personal branding feel free
to like and comment and engage in mine
as well as tag me and anything that
you're working on as long as it's not
SuperDuper technical and I can actually
understand what you're talking about but
we'll talk more about that in the next
section on August 26 but please check in
to our events calendar and stay tuned to
what we have coming up thank you all for
joining have a great rest of your day
thank you all
you